[Music]
that happens to me when I uh I eat ice
cream too fast I get all the my memories
from from the third grade start rushing
back into my brain
um yeah that's what happens to me when I
put my fork in a socket
[Music]
me too you know I am he's a crazy person
yes he's got sword programming I could I
could totally see Hayward installing
that put your put your fork in a socket
who's gonna clean up the glass who's
gonna clean up all of this all right oh
my gosh this is insane welcome back to
New rockstars you gave us your hottest
unanswered MCU questions and we said hot
dog what a great question so today hot
dog hot dog hot diggity dog what a good
question so today Mt and I will not only
answer those questions but theorize
where they can go we'll be focusing on
where the hell white vision is after
jumping through that uh
he said deuces uh we're gonna talk about
Moon Knight because you guys have asked
a lot about Moon Knight you've asked a
lot about Valentina and her mission to
kill Clint Barton and Hawkeye and we're
also going to dabble in the celestials
and the eternals because you guys had
questions about those too we're gonna
get really into this yes yeah we got the
questions to answers hey I bet you're
wondering where is Eric Voss he's on
vacation so me and Mt while the cat's
away yeah the dogs play we are here
we are here oh introductions you guys
this is inside Marvel new rockstars
weekly Marvel reaction show and we want
to thank nordvpn for sponsoring our show
today more on them in a little bit later
but first empty welcome yourself
introduce hello what's going on Jessica
I'm so excited to get into these topics
with you today we do miss Eric Eric is
not with us today he's gonna be out for
a couple of weeks but um we we do we we
do feel his spirit with us today as as I
do all the time
um especially during Christmas season I
hope your Christmas was good everybody
and YouTube Jessica I hope everyone felt
the Christmas spirit I felt the
Christmas Eric Voss Spirit he's the the
Ghost of Christmas present for me um is
Eric Boss guess which ghost he is he's
the Grumpy One
no he's the one that teaches me how to
have more Christmas cheer which is all
of them oh
and off that note
you guys you asked where is White Vision
or where do white Vision go so white
Vision was designed uh to beat Wanda in
the hex and during the standoff he faced
our wand division
um and also it took until now for me to
realize it's one division because that
vision is a Wanda version of vision so
it's one division either way it took me
too long to recognize that there's so
many layers with the title of wand image
it's like hey it's like television and
one division but it's also Wanda slash
Vision but it's also the Wanda version
of vision so many different things you
can interpret it
genuinely though good job writers you
great way to introduce it all to Disney
plus I loved it so this is when one
division touches white vision's forehead
gets him all his powers vision goes oh I
am vision and she jumps through the
ceiling so personally at we don't know
where it is there's nothing that has
been uh confirmed by Marvel Studios or
about any other shows really about where
white Vision could possibly be but being
a robot that was kind of sentient he was
built to destroy Wanda and the hex but
now he is a free in sentient you'd
probably do like exactly what a free
sentient robot would do and try
acquiring all information on all Globes
and any scale right that's how I assume
what happened uh he's forever curious
and forever just endlessly walking this
plane trying to find answers to not only
who he is but to the world itself how do
you feel about that no no for sure like
a vision is a person that is or the
being that is like highly curious and
but he's also he's a living computer and
like we learned from Ultron
um his father essentially that um Ultron
from the jump started downloading
everything on the internet it's like I
have to know what this world is about so
I can figure out how to best to defend
it and I feel like Vision in his own way
hasn't really gotten to experience the
world yet like he's always been either
like somebody else's property either
ultron's or um The Avengers or whatever
so like now he has his own being for the
first time in his life he's going to try
to probably experience the world and I
think that that's what Vision Quest
um the title of his show is sort of
implying it's like let's go on a journey
to discover who I am and like go on a
quest throughout the world to try to
figure that out so very I'm so excited
for Vision Quest I'm excited to see
where he's gonna go and I think that
what I what I said is the actual
question not more so where is White
Vision it's where will we see him next
where does he go next so it's like where
do we assume he's gonna show up in the
Cinematic Universe next now and keep in
mind what we know now like with even
Valentina being in charge of the CIA
creating a Thunderbolts team uh we have
armor Wars where do we think we'll see
white Vision next I I definitely feel
like armor Wars is um the most likely to
be like where was he at least a cameo
because like by extension of Ultron
vision is himself a piece of Stark
technology
um so he is probably going to be and
like we saw from from One Division that
he's a highly sought after weapon
because like sword made him sword tried
everything to turn him back on after on
his destruction and when they finally
did they lost him so like I feel like
that
um of getting Vision back is going to be
a huge part of Vision Quest but also
just a huge part of the MCU moving
forward
um that we could potentially see in
armor Awards as well
um but there is also potential that we
could see him in ironheart
um the uh the Iron Art Series in Chicago
in Chicago because like you know what we
who knows like Vision could be anywhere
you can fly about anywhere and that's
true you know Riri is very much invested
in trying to you know just follow in
Tony Stark's Footsteps in her own way
and like maybe something maybe she hacks
into something or like I don't know like
she just Vision needs riri's help
because she's the the most knowledgeable
of Stark technology in the world now
um now that's Tony Stark is gone but
like what do you think what what do you
think that we're gonna see I like that
and what I like about that is I like
that um what we had in the Iron Heart
Comics was a lot of her really closely
working with even like a hologram
version of uh Tony Stark but in reality
now and this in our new MCU she's
working with white Vision to make her
make her equipment more advanced that
would be sick I genuinely think he's
gonna run into the eternals and the
stars I think he is I think he is
chasing everything in everything and
nothing uh I think he checked out the
ship of thesis and I think he also is
just in the stars I think he's gonna run
into uh Harry Styles I think he's gonna
run into the ship with the rest of them
on there and then he's either gonna like
try to work with him and be like who are
you guys because he's going to be like
you're not humans but you're also not
me you're also not a robot person right
I would love to see Vision interact with
the eternals but I would also love to
see him interact with Adam Warlock
um from guardians 3 because like they're
sort of he has to they're very similar
in a way
um and like they both have like gems on
their foreheads and like it they could
be brothers yeah um a little cousin what
if they
no you don't think he's going to show up
in Guardians uh it would be a crazy
Cameo I don't think that he I think it's
very unlikely that he flew off into
space and like in a very uh Age of
Ultron any type way like Hulk I think
that he's probably on Earth
um maybe like he's maybe he's like going
through the ruins of uh Wonder Gore
looking for Wanda now that um he's you
know more himself
um or I feel like there's a good chance
that he possibly could have went to
Korea to go see his original Creator is
like a lot of people don't remember that
the actual creator of vision is not Tony
Stark it's not uh Bruce Banner it's not
even Ultron it is Helen Cho Helen Cho
Creator oh yeah Vision yes and she's
still alive yeah and she is still a
factor a huge factor in the MCU given
that Amadeus Joe is um a hero and they
is a Hulk um in the MCU and like now
that we have scar in uh from Shield
um on the on the board I feel like we're
gonna see more hulks introduced in the
MCU with the Amadeus Cho and I feel like
Vision Quest or whatever the next main
Vision title will probably introduce
reintroduce Helen Back to the MCU and uh
to introduce Amadeus Joe but also to
just like sort of help Vision understand
who he is because like if I'm lost and I
don't know who I am I'm gonna go talk to
my mama be like Mama what's the world
about I don't know nothing about the
world tell me about the world Mama also
you have a smart son are we Brothers I I
guess
brother little or big brother I don't
know when he was born oh my God that's
interesting that's a good one I think
there was a um the internet was taken by
storm when there when Paul Bettany made
a little a little hint as Paul Bettany
does that he might appear in Multiverse
of Madness and a lot of people were
asking where was white vision during
Multiverse Madness and also Spider-Man
no way home when everybody kind of
things shifted not only in time but in
like magic and do you think those things
affected white Vision or do you think
white Vision wasn't affected by those
things because he went into the hex
completely fine like when um once I
guess I I guess once Monica Rambo went
through the heck she was affected but
that's because she was human right or
that essentially what we know of so far
right but when uh White vision goes
through the hex and he's fighting
everybody he's still the same he's just
a violent sword created machine or not
sworn uh no what sword create a machine
but so it's like was is he not affected
by Magic and he's not affected by like
any kind of time disruptions well
actually I feel like
um well first of all he is definitely
affected by Magic in the sense that like
in order for him to have turned on in
one division they had to use chaos magic
to turn him on but other than that I
don't think that you know him being a
vibranium
um synthesoid a lot of he can absorb a
lot of energy and a lot of like magic
energy as well however I feel like there
is a chance here because he was turned
on by chaos Magic that Vision himself
could be susceptible to
um demonic influence not to sound like
my Asian mom my overly religious station
mom you do you do but I feel like there
is a huge chance that like much like
when Wu was influenced uh by the dweller
and darkness maybe Vision could be
receiving
um like maybe demonic signals from other
people which could be bad uh because I
feel like division white Vision looks a
lot like the Marvel Cosmic deity despair
it was like a white weird demon man so
it'd be really cool if Vision turned
into despair or something because he was
influenced that'd be kind of crazy that
would be insane
and oh my God okay so save that save
that for a theory video because that's a
great idea you guys we there's some more
questions that we want to get to but
first be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
all of the new rockstars merch you
didn't get for Christmas and I know
there's some that you guys missed and
they're still time to grab our latest
Obsession shirt inspired by black
panther which I am not currently wearing
but are you wearing it two black people
on the show we we rapping each other
we let them down we let them down I'm
not wearing mine right now but you know
why so you can go look it up yourself
and then go buy it because it's amazing
mine's in the wash because I've been
wearing it so much see there you go take
it from us you got to get it before the
film premieres on Disney plus which is
soon it's next month support the channel
and check out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
all right our second question for today
is Jessica will we get a Moon Knight
season two no
no they decided that boot night was so
lame that they'll never revisit them
again yeah essentially no here's why I'm
saying no and I'm so sorry so be
bursting everyone's better I'm coming
with facts on this okay so Moon Knight
clearly was a hit for all of us it was a
hit for critics everybody loved it I
loved it we left off being interested
introduced to Jake lockley the third
altar is still paired and working with
konshu and after being Terror at
terroret and seeing her Avatar become
Layla there's just like a million things
we absolutely could visit in season two
you guys and Oscar Isaac teased a ton of
different times which he shouldn't have
done but he did he teased different
times with the director in Egypt a
little bit of info during New York City
like uh sci-fi con I think but uh Marvel
actually has never given an official
statement to any of these things and
then on top of that it's little things
like them wanting an Emmy under limited
series because they're a limited series
and they've been mentioning how they're
not really taught Kevin feige hasn't
brought it up but it is still in fact a
limited series they said they're uh that
Moon Knight the character can inhabit it
inhabit any corner of the MCU which is
true I think he's great in any you could
throw him in anything and he's great but
I just think this was his origin or not
origin but our like introduction to him
so he could go to other things kind of
how like Miss Marvel is our introduction
so now she's going to the Marvels like
but this doesn't mean that we're not
gonna get like a spin-off I don't I
think I think midnight Sons is on its
way I stand by it yeah there's there's
no way that we're not getting a midnight
Suns project I feel like it's getting
teased because like we're in this new
darker phase of the MCU and like now
that um with especially with werewolf By
Night introducing like you know the the
Bloodstone which is a chaos element and
um you know these more darker players
like um like your Willows by Knights and
your your man things yeah they're
they're definitely meaning to bring
about all these dark side Heroes to uh
say below midnight Suns so that's
definitely happening as for moonlight
season two those are some really good
points
um especially the enemy points um that
they it was under limited series however
I do feel like however they are going to
do a season two eventually I think that
season two there's just too many
threads that were left behind like that
were very personal to markets but like
Jake lockley in his inner struggle like
it we know from um when he went to the
uh the afterlife that he and Mark didn't
exactly finish like they didn't exactly
resolve their um their balance on their
inner balance and I think that that's
what Jake lockley in season two of moon
Knight's going to do yeah um well and
also Bushman like we they teased Bushmen
yeah they didn't really um go into that
which is like they're definitely 100
gonna get into that as well
um so yeah but like like you said they
don't necessarily have to do that
because like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is so big but we can easily see
the Moon Knight story continued in um in
Midnight Suns and like that's part of
that narrative that'd be really dope to
see as well but like I just feel like
it'd be really cool to see like at
another Moon night installation firstly
also this is just for you guys watching
when I say no I would love a moon night
season too I love it I'm just thinking
practically especially that no one's
really talking about it it's kind of
like She-Hulk left a lot of unanswered
questions too and so did Miss Marvel and
so did this and that's on the writers
and the show Runners more than it is on
Kevin feige so they're leaving it open
so they can get the opportunity to get a
season two because they would love to do
it again why wouldn't you want to do it
again you guys have a great writer's
room you want your project to go further
but that is on the flagster and
everybody else
again though it is I think the opening
is still there and I think because we're
getting into Gods we have our like
Egyptian god right here and then we're
getting into uh not metaphysical but
like uh kind of uh like just the scary
stuff I think we have an opportunity to
see Moon uh Moon Knight literally
everywhere and they can finish a lot of
those stories I think it's just the
story of like Ethan Hawke's character
and being the Avatar like I don't know
how that's going to be answered in other
properties
but yeah I think I feel like Ethan Hawke
is done with the MCU I feel like he had
that one that's what I thought and he's
done and he should be but if you kill I
think this was a question that was
brought up and I I it might have been
answered but when you kill him doesn't
that release his God and they shot him
at the end hmm I think the implication
was that like
a country wanted to get rid of the God
as well like both of them because like
they tied the soul to the god they tied
the God's Soul being to Arthur Hero's
physical form so I think Concho was like
all right we're gonna get rid of you for
real for real now
um because you were a threat so I don't
know
um but they could go either way with
that really
things you can do in season two just
give them a season two just give them a
season two I'm sure there's been other
Emmy shows that were nominated for
limited series and then was like huh
well now we're gonna make a second
season
money gotta be made like come on Mega
season two just do it just do it I'd
love it oh you guys that was that was
just answer your second question uh we
want to thank the folks that helped
bring inside Marvel to you and first we
especially want to thank nordvpn we
watch a lot of movies and series here at
new rockstars and one thing that makes
it easier is nordvpn with nordvpn you
can change your virtual location with
just one click which makes it easier to
find streaming platforms at a lower
price and we can even access platforms
that aren't available in the US with
just one click you can choose from over
5400 servers and over 60 countries that
way we never miss out on our favorite
content whether we're at home or
traveling and if you're worried that
nordvpn might cause buffering when
you're watching content if you're not
norvpn provides amazing speed thanks to
Nord links so you can stream securely
without bandwidth Broadway nor vpn's
benefits and features go Way Beyond
improving your streaming experience you
can also access games and discounts only
available in other regions and block
malware written websites while you
explore securely we encourage you to try
nordvpn for yourself so grab your
exclusive nor VPN deal by going to
nordvpn.com Marvel to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus four
additional months for free it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee that's n o r d
vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive discount
plus four month for free if you had just
downloaded all of your memories into a
robotic copy of yourself you would
probably want a good night's sleep I
know I would and here at new rockstars
We Trust Helix to protect our sleep with
the best mattresses in the world me and
Mt both have ux mattresses and we love
them I yeah I sleep so well now I had a
bad I had a bad bed for like 12 years
and then I got a helix mattress and now
I sleep like a baby it is so good it's
like the difference is like night and
day it feels so nice Helix sleep has a
quiz that just takes two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you which is extremely
important everybody's unique and Helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have a soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot mattress is
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers
like myself uh you guys I can't get
enough of this Helix mattress I I love
it so much I have to fight my cat for it
all the time let's go to helixsleep.com
inside marble take their two minute
sleep quiz it's super quick you guys you
can do this and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life I promise
guaranteed they have 10 year warranty
you guys a 10-year warranty a decade and
you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel so go check
it out right now it's in the description
too okay Mt Why did Valentina hire Elena
to kill Clint you were the one that I
talked to about this because you brought
it up to me that it wasn't Valentina
that was hired yes
um it was a uh Eleanor Bishop um if I'm
not yes misremembering that uh that
needed to that needed Hawkeye handled so
she contacted uh Miss Valentina and
Valentina is the one who who set
everything up so yeah like I'm wondering
what's going on there yeah it's and it's
also yeah so the question that keeps
getting asked everywhere is just like
now that we know that it's Eleanor that
actually hired Valentina to hire uh now
that we know that Eleanor that hired
Valentina to get Elena to kill Clint
it's more it's like also okay so what's
Eleanor's motive and she's working with
Kingpin and then we know that everybody
is out for Clint because of the whole
Ronin situation but Valentina is now
head of the CIA was she head of the CIA
during this and is she is this like
so there's a lot of questions so is she
head of the CIA during this but then is
she also wrapping up the Thunderbolts is
that why she hired Elena
I feel like what we're seeing with Val
is Val's Val's essentially doing what
Norman Osborne did during the dark rain
run and Val is he's basically trying to
infiltrate her way in um world
governments well right now American
governments and uh well also the
criminal underworld so that she can
control everything and right now with
the with wakanda forever we see we're
seeing her basically erect herself to
becoming the head of the CIA by you know
basically selling out
um Mr uh friend of wakanda I forget his
name why would Blake get his name
Everett Ross ever Ross yes Everett Ross
so I feel like
um by the end or eventually we're going
to see
um Valentina essentially just being like
hey criminal underworld I can help you
get away with stuff because now I'm the
head of like the CIA and like everyone
trusts me so like you know Kingpin you
can do this in like the hood you can do
this is basically a assembling like all
the major players
um and having control of the world
um on the low I a I love the idea that
we're getting a piece of that in a
Hawkeye or well technically the end of
Black Widow it was like here's her at
work this is what she's probably gonna
be doing with the Thunderbolts here's
her at work right now secondly she you
think she's pulling in Amanda Waller and
like forming her out like just that's
what she's doing on the Lolo I I feel
like her CIA position is eventually
going to give her the authority to
assemble an Avengers like team with the
Thunderbolts
um and I feel like it's just I feel like
there's a there's a weird sense of fear
coming to the MCU to the people to the
normal people of the MCU with all these
mutants and all this stuff coming up and
they'll they'll look to
um Contessa Valentina to for for
guidance and she's gonna be like all
right we need a new Avengers team so I'm
gonna make the Thunderbolts but they're
secretly going to be working for my
secret agenda because I'm working with
all the criminals yeah and so like
Elena who's thinking that she's gonna
you know finally be on a good team just
like her sisters like you know what I'm
gonna if my sister can can change her
ways I can too it's like oh no I'm
working for a bad person too whoops like
sister like sister not again what the
interesting part is like Valentina
choosing Elena she could have chose
anyone but I think it's easier to get
someone like Elena get someone that
already has a motive and you have to
create that motive right so I think
um Valentina hiring Yelena was just out
of like Coincidence of like oh well this
person has the most reason to kill Clint
when she finds out once I tell her the
truth like so it's like I and we need to
remember how smart Valentina is she's
sneaky she's conniving she can do all
these things so much quicker than anyone
else can so she's already like 12 steps
ahead when we see her so in Black Widow
what we saw her hiring Elena she's
actually 12 steps ahead so she's
probably got everybody under her belt
right now no I feel like the reason why
that was a really good point because
like what she is essentially did at the
end of Black Widow was like hey I'm here
to help you by you helping me it's like
you want to kill this guy because he
basically killed your sister so like you
know what let's continue our working
relationship because I'm a nice person
you killed this person and then we'll
talk about maybe a Thunderbolts that I
don't know but yeah we're we're best
basically it was also it wasn't okay so
there's also this P this piece that
wasn't helpful that was like her friend
that was once a black widow telling her
oh after you're becoming Black Widow you
need to do contractor work you need to
get paid to kill right so I have this
girl Valentina that hires me well I
don't know if she introduced them but
it's like Valentina is her contractor is
her like informant basically is the
person that gives her the jobs that gets
them both paid allegedly we don't know
if valentina's actually getting paid or
she's getting higher I mean like we know
from the end of Black Widow that um not
ever Ross General Ross was like
basically going through the wreckage of
everything and like I feel like the
government probably got involved with
like what happened to the people after
the Red Room and so like if if um
valentina's in charge of the CIA maybe
she's using her resources to sort of
like find all these women and uh use
them to her Advantage 100 it makes sense
does Wilson Fisk how does Wilson Fisk
fit into this if Wilson Fisk and Eleanor
were working together do you think this
was also a situation that Wilson Fisk
wanted to get Ronan out of the way or
Clint out of the way maybe because I
remember that in Hawkeye the whole thing
between Echo and wasn't Fisk was like oh
you killed my dad bad you were in charge
of killing my dad and maybe he wanted to
tie up those loose ends and be like well
Clint can't talk to her so we gotta kill
him too do you think Wilson Fisk had
anything to do with it I think that this
was mainly just like an Eleanor Bishop
thing that like you know obviously
involves Wilson Fisk because like you
know that whole Ronin situation
um but I feel like
um Val is going to be helping Wilson's
Fisk sort of Rise back to the top of
where he used to be because it doesn't
look like he's doing all that hot from
Hawkeye no he's in a Hawaiian shirt yeah
I think we're right he's going through a
bit of a power struggle within his own
organization right now uh maybe with his
own son that'd be really cool and
interesting oh yeah I feel like Val's
going to be like hey let me scratch her
back you scratch mine when you were in
power again I love this because that was
making moves that was going to be one of
the biggest players in the obviously in
the MCU outside of Kang
um she's literally 100 reshape the world
she is playing that's why I'm okay we'll
get into that this part later but I was
like that's why I'm like I'm excited for
Thunderbolt Ross to come back but I'm
also like I thought Valentino was just
gonna take this place by storm anyways
so right whatever whatever you want to
come for me uh our last question which I
want to hand up to you Mt because you
have have a lot of information on this
what role will the eternals and
celestials play going forward now that's
a really good question and like it's
going to be a huge role like eternals
was probably one of the the biggest
title of phase four the most influential
title of phase four uh because it's it
essentially told us how the universe
came to be and what the the plan for the
universe is and with the
eternals being whisked away by um
erishem to basically go through their
memories to see if humanity is worthy
that invented itself could possibly
trigger a new host of the celestials
could possibly trigger and apocalyptic
events where they come we saw from
guardians why now they came and to
destroyed that planet with um the Power
Stone essentially that could potentially
happen to humanity where
um the celestials are like all right you
guys are causing too much trouble we
reset the experiment and we uh we we go
to see where Humanity where um the Earth
ends up a couple million years from now
but like knowing what we know from
Eternal that the celestials basically
keep all the light in the universe
running what happens if all the
celestials die like because we know that
you know Druid does not like the
celestials at all and he's on his way to
go see them what if he finds a way to
kill all the celestials I feel like
that's what's going to be the major
narrative going forward because if all
the celestials die then Darkness raids
in the universe you can't that's why I
would hope that Druid would learn is
like if you kill all them you're killing
all these innocent lives exactly of
people that's interesting also I hate to
throw this wrench in that we saw a
Celestial correct uh and Thor and Thor
love and thunder at the meeting so how
important are they if they're just
hanging out with Zeus you think that
they're all Mighty they're all whatever
and then you see all of them kind of
hanging out here and it's like I thought
you were all above everything
so it's like how does that throw wrench
in it I I think that you know I love
seeing the celestials hanging out with
the gods because like I I have always
had this feeling that gods and
celestials basically have the same job
it's like we're supposed to manage the
light and all the people of the of the
universe like make sure that everyone
stays alive and stays safe if for that
purpose and so but like they got so used
to their job and so and so like bored
with it it's like you know what we're
just chilling like people are they're
just like peons and like we're just
we're just like living the our lives out
of luxury and like they they worship us
and we get the power and it's great and
so it's like it's sort of like I don't
know sort of like a break room of like
really lacks rulers which is like well
who cares you know we're just chilling
whatever because they all have the same
job so I feel like it makes sense for
the celestials in these journals
starting out together I guess I need to
take a break that and the fact that like
okay so we know that after TM up was
stopped
um they their punishment so far that we
know of is just taking the three that
are on earth and taking them away so are
they just going to ignore and allow
tiama to just lay in the ground halfway
up that's that's the question it's like
do they resurrect uh Tiamat if they can
um and and sort of like re-trigger the
emergence and make that happen
um that's actually a good question like
can Tiamat even be saved resurrect um or
it's Tiamat like fully Dead storyline
wise I think it's easier and I think uh
just to make him like become an island
to make this become like an island in
the middle of the ocean and just be like
yeah this is the island that's now a
dead kind of almost made Celestial
um but it would be so great 10 years
from now if Marvel did want to talk
about the celestials being able to
resurrect their own
um they have to they have well maybe not
because then we have the skull of
nowhere just floating and they never
resurrected him right I mean like So
Dope if we got like Marvel Zombies but
celestials if they if they're not
freaking resurrected in the what if
Zombies episode I would literally lose
my [ __ ] that would be banana insane
that would be oh no what's a god what's
a god what's a devil anymore when you
have a zombie Celestial right
Jesus Christ you guys that is it for our
episode of inside Marvel we answer some
of the questions that you guys have been
asking us over time thank you guys so
much for your questions yeah thank you
yeah thank you guys for sending in your
questions I really appreciate it also
it's like some of them have hard like
cemented answers from just from Studio
opinion but a lot of them are just
theorizing until we get into phase five
and figure out what they can do a lot of
these things sit on the back burner and
then they remember it later and they're
like oh we can address this now uh this
will be fun to come back to and I'm that
is how I feel about white Vision they
were like we're holding on to this we're
holding on to this for when we want to
jump back into it will we see him in
Agatha I don't know I just think he's
gonna be sitting there for a minute
until they're like yeah yeah
what Vision you guys don't forget to
check out our merch at new
rockstarsmerch.com and if you're over 18
click the link in our buy their bio
click the link down below for our new
rockstars Discord server in the
description and join the conversation
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Mt at Master attainment subscribe
to inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast and thanks for watching we'll
see you next week love you guys
foreign